the thing that is shocking to me is and
that's my new work part of my new work
isn't so much whether something is right
or wrong
it's the fact that how come
something can be deemed as Wrong by
individuals
can be and and considered as true by the
collective
okay
if you take a cab driver a cab driver
knows that you can forecast okay
that you have to have a buffer but if
you collectively put people together
they start leaving a stock market all
kind of
lunacies okay
and and all kind of stuff this is what
shocks me about about it so so fat Tony
has a saying
it's easier to scam people with billions
than scam them with thousands
and it's a lot easier to fool the
multitude than fool a single person
and we know from social epistemology
from contagions from something called
informational Cascades that this is
entirely true so you have here you've
had over the past 30 years a clustering
of opinion in Academia and everything's
dominated but it's like almost the same
Economist who's wrong by the way
so and you supply them with the truth
it's like your statistical method don't
work in the tails hence robustness you
can't compute these risks because
they're uncomputable you supply them
with the fact that you can't forecast
don't let people be suckers by relying
on a forecast error you're supplying
with all these facts and guess what you
get
nothing
but this is well known in medicine and
in medicine it Bears the name
translational Gap
like it took 200 years for doctors to
shed to stop killing patients because if
you have pneumonia you multiply your
chance of death by four if you're bled
you know you know and bleeding was a
standard procedure they bled you first
and then started the conversation that
was and no doctor wanted to do anything
that other doctors didn't do but and
they knew they were killing patients
individually you see but that was a
profession it's the same thing in
economics same thing and forecasting
the IMF never got anything right the
last time I had a nervous nervous I had
a anger fit was number two of the IMF
some schmuck called Dr Cato I'm on a
record here so so now anything I say
about public affairs and private is
public that's my uh
my ethic
Professor Mr Cato
was in Korea presenting the poor Korean
2500 people in the room with the
forecast by the IMF for 2010 11 12 13
and 14.
okay
and and my uh my rage came from the fact
that
Mr Cato show him your forecasts for 2007
and eight and nine made in 2001 to three
four five and six
had you done that you'd realize that
it's totally unreliable
but guess what
he's made to forecast that's their
business or he's not gonna stop a crisis
is not going to be you know say oh
what's the crisis all right just like
what's the death of it
million patients right
to stop them from their methods that's
the problem of stickiness it's called
institutional stickiness Mother Nature
doesn't do that this way Mother Nature
kills it doesn't have tenure so it acts
by destroying not by teaching or
preaching all right
so and and what am I when I did my model
of a perfect Society it would be
something in which people like that
would be destroyed naturally organically
now so institutions keep things around
okay so the the and the problem is of
course I had these poor 2500 suckers
taking notes on his forecasts okay
thinking they're real
groups never admit failure a group would
rather keep living in a mythology of we
were oppressed than ever admit failure
individuals are the only ones who admit
failure even individuals don't like to
admit failure but eventually they can be
forced to a group will never admit they
were wrong a group will never admit we
made a mistake because a group that
tries to change its mind falls apart so
I'm hard-pressed in history to find
examples of large groups where they've
said we thought a but the answer is
actually B usually what happens in that
case is a Schism where you go from
Catholic Church to Protestant and so on
there's a Divergence and usually a lot
of infighting this happens in crypto
land too where the coins Fork Bitcoin
doesn't suddenly say we should have had
smart contracts or eth doesn't suddenly
say we should have been immutable I was
kind of bored of a foundation that was
charged with giving out money for a
cause and I found it very disillusioning
because what I learned was that no
matter what the foundation did they
would declare Victory they would give
money for a certain thing that would
support a certain project and every
project was Victorious every project
project was a success there was a lot of
back slapping there was a lot of high
sounding mission statements and vision
statements a lot of congratulations a
lot of nice dinners but nothing ever got
done and what I realized was because
there was no objective feedback because
there is no loss it's all social profit
they couldn't fail and because they
couldn't fail they misdirected resources
all day long and eventually of course
such groups run around money if you want
to change the world to a better place
the best way to do it as a for-profit
because for-profits have to take
feedback from reality ironically
for-profit entities are more sustainable
than non-profit entities they're
self-sustainable you're not out there
with a begging bull all the time now of
course you lose the beautiful non-profit
status you have to pay your taxes and
also you can get corrupted by being
purely for profit but I would argue that
the best businesses are the ones that
long term are both for-profit
sustainable and ethical so you can
attract the best people you can sustain
it because it's a mission it's not just
about the money because it's diminishing
returns to making money this admission
marginal utility and money in your life
so I learned that if you want to change
the world you're probably better off
trying to do it with a for-profit and
now I will leave you with some
insightful quotes Madness is rare in
individuals but in groups parties
Nations and ages it is the rule nature
it is not famine not earthquakes not
microbes not cancer but man himself who
is man's greatest danger to man for the
simple reason that there is no adequate
protection against psychic epidemics
which are infinitely more devastating
than the worst of natural catastrophes
Carl Young whenever you find yourself on
the side of the majority it is time to
pause and reflect Mark Twain be a free
thinker and don't accept everything you
hear as truth be critical and evaluate
what you believe in Aristotle against
the corrosive stickiness of Institutions
let me close with a famous quote from
Nobel Prize physicist Richard feyman
science is the belief in the ignorance
of the experts
so that's all for today's nuggets and if
you also want to get the best nuggets
from books I recommend you to check out
short form which is a platform that I
personally love using because I can
learn from many books in a super
efficient way surephone is not
sponsoring this video but I do have an
affiliate link which is surefun.com
piggy nuggets and you can use it to get
a 5 day free trial on a 20 discount on
the annual subscription